The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or to view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: I want to start out
today by reviewing what we
covered last time.
We sort of covered two lectures
of material, but a
little bit lightly last time
because I want to spend more
time starting today dealing with
wave forms and functions.
We will get notes on that
very, very shortly.
To review quantization, we
started out by talking about
scalar quantizers, in other
words, the thing that we want
to do is to take a sequence of
real numbers and each of those
real numbers we want to
quantizers it into one of a
finite set of symbols.
Then, of course, the symbols
we're going to
encode later on.
So basically what we're doing is
we're taking the real line,
we're splitting it into a bunch
of regions, r1, r2, r3.
The last region of the
first region goes
off to minus infinity.
The last region goes off
to plus infinity.
So that clearly, if there's a
lot of probability over in
here or a lot of probably over
in here, you're going to have
a very large distortion.
So, when we talk more about that
later and talk about how
to avoid it and why we
should avoid it and
all of these things.
We then talked about these
Lloyd-Max conditions for
minimum mean square error.
What we said last time was
suppose somebody gives you
these representation points,
which you're going to use to
represent the actual number on
the real line that comes out.
Then you ask when some
particular number occurs
should we encode it into this
point or into this point?
If our criterion is mean square
error, and that's what
our criterion is normally going
to be, then we're going
to minimize the mean square
error for this particular
point by mapping it here, if
that's the most probable --
we're going to map it here if
this is the closest point, and
that's the closest point.
Because by doing this we
minimize the squared error
between b and a1 or b and a2.
So, that says that we're going
to define these regions to
have the separations between
the regions at the bisector
points between the
representation points.
So that says that one of the
Lloyd-Max conditions for
minimum mean square error is you
always want to choose the
regions in such a way that
they're the mid-points between
the representation points.
Any minimum mean square error
quantizers has to satisfy this
condition for each of the j's.
Namely, for each of these
points they have to be
mid-points.
Then the other thing that we
observed is that once we
choose these regions, the way
we want to choose the
representation points to
minimize the mean square error
is we now have to look at the
probability density on this
real line and we have to choose
these points to be the
conditional means within the
representation area.
That just comes out by formula
to be the expected value of
the random variable u, which is
this value as it occurs on
the real line.
The expected value of that
conditional on being in region
rj is just the integral
of u times the
conditional density of u.
The conditional density of u
is the real density of u
divided by the probability
of being in that region.
So all of this is very simple.
I hope you see it as something
which is almost trivial,
because if you don't see it as
something simple, go back and
look at it because, in fact,
this is not rocket science
here, this is just what
you would normally do.
So Lloyd-Max algorithm then
says alternate between the
conditions for the mid-points
between the regions and the
conditional means.
The Lloyd-Max conditions are
necessary but not sufficient.
In other words, any time you
find a minimum mean square
error quantization, it's going
to satisfy those conditions.
But if you find a set of points,
b sub j, and a set of
points, a sub j, which satisfy
those conditions, it doesn't
necessarily mean that
you have a minimum.
In other words, there are often
multiple sets of points
which satisfy the Lloyd-Max
conditions, and one or more of
those is going to be optimum,
is going to be the smallest
one, and the others are not
going to be optimum.
In other words, the algorithm
is a local hill-climbing
algorithm, which finds the best
thing it can find which
is close to where it's starting
at some very strange
sense of close.
The close is not any sense of
mean square error, but close
is defined in terms of where the
algorithm happens to go.
So an example of that that we
talked about last time is
where you have three spikes
of probability.
Two of them are smaller and
one of them is bigger.
One of them is at minus 1, one
of them is at zero, one of
them is at plus 1.
One solution to the Lloyd-Max
conditions is this one here
where a1 is sitting right in
the middle of the spike.
Therefore, any time that the
sample value of the random
variable is over here, you get
virtually no distortion.
The other point is sitting at
the conditional mean between
these two points.
So it's a little closer
to this one than it
is to this one --
I hope the figure shows that.
Any time you wind up here or
here, you get this amount of
the distortion.
Now without making any
calculations you just look at
this and you say well,
this spike is bigger
than this spike is.
Therefore, it makes sense if
we're going to do this kind of
strategy to put a 2 underneath
that spike, therefore, getting
a very small distortion any
time the big spike occurs.
Then a1 is going to be midway
between these two points, and
you get the larger amount of
distortion there but now it's
a less probable event.
So you can easily check that
both of these solutions
satisfy the Lloyd-Max
conditions, but one of them
turns out to be optimal and the
other one turns out to be
not optimal.
If you fiddle around with it
for a while, you can pretty
much convince yourself that
those are the only solutions
to the Lloyd-Max algorithm for
this particular problem.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: When there's a
region that has zero
probability throughout, and the
Lloyd-Max algorithm tries
to find the mean for that
region, it's going to find
somewhere outside the region,
it will find zero as the
expected value.
But that might not necessarily
be inside that region, what
does it do in that case?
PROFESSOR: What does
it do in that case?
Well, I don't think you
can argue that it's
going to be at zero.
I think you have to argue that
it might be anywhere that it
wants to be.
Therefore, what the algorithm is
going to do when you start
with a certain set of
representation points --
well, if you start with a
certain set of representation
points that picks that separater
wherever it happens
to be, than this particular
point you're talking about is
going to be at some completely
unimportant place.
You know eventually the thing
that's going to happen is that
this thing that's in a region of
no probability is going to
spread out and include something
that has some
probability, and then you're
going to nail that region with
some probability.
I can't prove this to you, and
I'm not even sure that it's
always true, but I think if you
try a couple of examples
you will see that it sort
of does the right thing.
AUDIENCE: But in the algorithm,
you replace the
point at the point of expected
value in that region.
So, the algorithm doesn't know
what to do at that point.
It crashes.
PROFESSOR: Well, unless you're
smart enough to write the
program to do something
sensible, yes.
AUDIENCE:
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE].
PROFESSOR: Yes.
And you have to write
it so it'll do
something reasonable then.
The best thing to do is to start
out without having any
of the regions have
zero probability.
AUDIENCE: We have that
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE].
PROFESSOR: All right.
Well then you have to use
some common sense on it.
So, after that we say OK, well
just like when we were dealing
with discrete source coding,
any time we finish talking
about encoding a single letter,
we talk about what
happens when you
encode multiple
letters in the same way.
Somebody is bound to think of
the idea of encoding multiple
real numbers all together.
So they're going to think of
the idea of taking this
sequence of real numbers,
segmenting it into blocks of n
numbers each and then taking
the set of n numbers and
trying to find a reasonable
quantization for that.
In that case, the quantization
points are
going to be n vectors.
The regions are going
to be regions in
n dimensional space.
Well, if you think about it
a little bit, these n
dimensional representation
points, if you're given them,
the place where you're going to
establish the regions then
is on the perpendicular
bisectors
between any two points.
Namely, for each two points
you're going to establish a
perpendicular bisector between
those two points, you're going
to do that for all
sets of points.
You're going to take regions
which are enclosed by all of
those perpendicular bisectors,
and you call
those the voronoi region.
Remember, I drew an example of
it last time that looked
something like this.
You have various
points around.
It's hard to draw it in more
than two dimensions.
So these perpendicular
bisectors go
like this and so forth.
I think you can show that you've
never had the situation
-- interesting problem if you
want to play with it.
I don't think you can have that,
but I'm not sure why.
Anyway, you do have these
voronoi regions.
You have these perpendicular
bisectors that you set up in
two dimensional space or in
high dimensional space.
Then given those regions
you can then establish
representation points, which are
at the conditional means
within those regions.
You really have the same problem
that you had before,
it's just a much grubbier
problem because it's using
vectors, it's an n dimensional
space.
For this reason this problem
was enormously popular for
many, many years, because
many people loved the
complexity of it.
It was really neat
to write computer
programs that did this.
Back in those days you had to
be careful about computer
programs because computation
was very, very slow, and it
was a lot of fun.
When you get all done with it,
you don't gain much by doing
any of that.
The one thing that you do gain
is that if you take square
regions, namely, if you take a
whole bunch of points which
are laid out on a rectangular
grid and you take regions
which are now little rectangles
or little squares,
and you look at them for a
while, you say that's not a
very good thing to do.
A better thing to do is to take
all this two dimensional
space, for example, and to fill
it in to tile it we say
with hexagons as opposed to
tiling it with rectangles or
to tiling it with squares.
If you tile it with hexagons,
for given amount of area you
get a smaller mean
square error.
If you could tile it with
circles that would be the best
of all, but when you try to tile
it with circles you find
out there's all this stuff left
in the middle, like if
you've ever tried to tile a
floor with circles you find
out you have to fill it
in somehow and it's
a little bit awkward.
So hexagons work,
circles don't.
If you then go on to a higher
number of dimensions, you get
the same sort of thing
happening, you get these nice
n dimensional shapes
which will tile
n dimensional volume.
As n gets larger and larger,
these tiling volumes become
closer and closer to spheres,
and you can prove all sorts of
theorems about that.
But the trouble is when you
get all done you haven't
gained very much, except you
have a much more complex
problem to solve.
But you don't have a much
smaller mean square
distortion.
So you can still
use Lloyd-Max.
Lloyd-Max still has as many
problems as it had before in
finding local minima.
With a little bit of thought
about it you can see it's
going to have a lot
more problems.
Because visualize starting
Lloyd-Max out where your
points are on a square grid and
where your regions now are
a little square.
So in other words, like this.
Try to think of how the
algorithm is going to go from
that to the hexagons that
you would rather have.
You can see pretty easily that
it's very unlikely that the
algorithm was ever going to
find its way to hexagons,
which by looking at it a little
further away we can see
it's clearly a good
thing to do.
In other words, Lloyd-Max
algorithm
doesn't have any vision.
It can't see beyond
its own nose.
It just takes these points and
looks for regions determined
by neighboring points, but it
doesn't have the sense to look
for what kind of structure
you want.
So anyway, Lloyd-Max becomes
worse and worse in those
situations and the problem
gets uglier and uglier.
Then, as we said last time, we
stop and think and we said
well gee, we weren't solving
the right problem anyway.
As often happens when a problem
gets very popular,
people start out properly by
saying well I don't know how
to solve the real problem
so I'll try
to solve a toy problem.
Then somehow the toy problem
gets a life of its own because
people write many papers about
it and students think since
there are many papers
about it, it must be
an important problem.
Then since there are these open
problems, students can
solve those open problems and
get PhD theses, and then they
got a in a university, and the
easiest thing for them to do
is to get 10 students working on
the same class of problems
and you see what happens.
I'm not criticizing the students
who do that or the
faculty members who do it,
they're all trapped in this
kind of crazy system.
Anyway, the right problem that
we should have started with is
when we look at the problem of
quantization followed by
discrete source coding, we
should have said that what
we're interested in is not the
number of quantization levels,
but rather the entropy of the
set of quantization levels.
That's the important thing
because that's the thing that
determines how many bits we're
going to need to encode these
symbols that come out
of the quantizer.
So the problem we'd like to
solve is to find the minimum
mean square error quantizer
for a given representation
point entropy.
In other words, whatever set of
points you have, you want
to minimize the entropy
of that set of points.
What that's going to do is to
give you a larger set of
points, but some points with
a very small probability.
Therefore, those points with a
very small probability are not
going to happen very often.
Therefore, they don't affect
the entropy very much, and
therefore, you get a lot of gain
in terms of mean square
error by using these very
improbable points.
That's a very nasty
problem to solve.
And again, we said well
let's try to solve a
simpler version of it.
A simpler version of it is first
to go back to the one
dimensional case and then say
OK, what happens if we just
use a uniform quantizer, because
that's what most
people use in practice anyway.
If we use a uniform quantizer
and we talk about a high rate
uniform quantizer, in other
words, we make the
quantization points close
together, what's going to
happen in that case?
Well, the probability of each
quantization region in that
case is going to be close to the
size of the representation
interval, in other words, of
the quantization interval,
times the probability density
within that interval.
Namely, if we have a probability
density and that
probability density is smooth,
then if you take very, very
small intervals you're going to
have a probability density
that doesn't change much
within that interval.
Therefore, the probability of
the interval is just going to
be the size of that quantization
interval -- in a
uniform quantizer you'll make
all of the intervals the same
-- times the density within
that integral.
Then we say OK, let's look at
what the entropy is of that
set of points, of the set of
points where the probabilities
are chosen to be some small
delta times the probability
density there.
I'm going through a slightly
simpler kind of argument today
than I did last time, and I'll
explain why I'm doing
something simpler today and
why I did something more
complicated then.
So this entropy is
this quantity.
If we now substitute delta times
the density for pj here,
we get the sum over j of this
delta pj, which is the
probability density times the
logarithm of delta pj.
Well now look, the logarithm of
delta pj is just logarithm
of delta plus logarithm of pj.
So we're taking the sum over all
the probability space of
logarithm of delta.
That comes out.
So we get a minus log delta, and
what's left is minus the
sum of delta pj log pj.
Does that look like something?
That looks exactly like the
approximation to an integral
that you always talk about.
Namely, if you look at a
Reimann integral, the
fundamental way to define a
Reimann integral is in terms
of splitting up that integral
into lots of little
increments, taking the value of
the function in each one of
those increments, multiplying
it by the size of the
increments and adding
them all up.
In fact, we're going to do that
a little later today when
I try to explain to you what
the difference is between
Reimann integration and
Lebesgue integration.
should Don't be frightened
if you've never taken any
mathematics courses, because
if people had taught you
Lebesgue integration when you
were freshmen at MIT or
seniors in high school or
whenever you learned about
integration, it would have
been just as simple as
teaching about Reimann
integration.
One is no simpler and no more
complicated than the other, so
we're really going back to study
something you should
have learned about five
years ago, maybe.
So anyway, when we represent
this as an integral, we get
this thing called the
differential entropy, which is
the integral of p of u minus
p of u times log of p of u.
So the entropy of the discrete
representation is minus log
delta plus this differential
entropy.
The mean square error in this
uniform quantizer, the
conditional means according to
this approximation are right
in the middle of
the intervals.
So we have a uniform probability
interval of width
delta, a point right in the
middle of it, and even I can
integrate that to find the mean
square error in it, which
is delta squared over 12, which
I think you've done at
least once in the
homework by now.
So I said I was going to tell
you why I went through doing
it this simpler way this time
and put in a lot more
notation last time.
If you really try to trace
through what the
approximations are here, the
way we did it last time is
much, much better, because then
you can trace through
what's happening in those
approximations, and you can
see, as delta goes to zero,
what's happened.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: This may be an obvious
question, why did you
substitute delta with pj
[INAUDIBLE PHRASE]?
PROFESSOR: Oh, why did I--?
OK, this is the probability of
the representation of the j's
representation point.
This is the probability
density around that
representation point.
The assumption I'm making here
is that f of u was constant
over that interval.
And if the density is constant
over the interval, if I have a
density which is constant over
an interval of width delta,
than the probability of landing
in that interval is
the width times the height.
AUDIENCE: I think there's
a typo in your
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE].
PROFESSOR: A typo?
AUDIENCE:
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE].
PROFESSOR: Yes, yes, yes.
I'm sorry, yes.
I'm blind today.
I knew what I meant so
well that I didn't --
thank you.
s of uj.
Yes.
Then I take out the delta and
what I'm left with is the
delta f of uj times the
log of f of uj.
Thank you.
When I look at that it's delta
times the probability density
times the log of the probability
density.
If I convert that now into an
interval when delta is very
small, I get this thing called
the differential entropy.
Does that make a little
more sense?
So your question was obvious,
it was just that
I was a total dummy.
So let's summarize what
all of that says.
In the scalar case
we're saying --
I have said but I have
not shown --
that a uniform scalar quantizer
approaches an
optimal scaler quantizer.
I haven't explained it all
in class why that's true.
There's an argument in the
notes that points it out.
You can read that there.
It's just another optimization,
but it's true if
you're looking at a higher
and higher rate, a scaler
quantizer where delta gets
smaller and smaller, then in
general what you need is to take
a different size delta
for each quantization region and
then look at what happens
when you try to optimize over
that and you find out that you
want to make all of the
deltas the same.
The required number of encoded
bits per symbol depends only
on h of u and on delta.
This is the most important
part of all of this.
It says that as you change this
differential entropy, if
you try to draw a curve between
H of v and MSE, and
there's a curve like that drawn
in the notes, if you
change the differential entropy,
it just shift this
curve left and right.
For a given value of h of u,
this is a universal curve.
In other words, as you change
delta, this quantity changes
and this quantity changes.
That's the only variable which
is left in here at this point.
When you make delta half as
big, if you want to get a
higher rate quantizer,
what happens?
Your mean square error goes
down by a factor of four.
Delta squared goes down to 1/4
of its previous value.
What happens here,
at log of delta?
Delta has changed by
a factor of 1/2.
H of v goes up by one bit.
So you take one more bit in your
quantizer and you get a
mean square error, which
is four times as small.
Any time you think of what kind
of accuracy you need on a
computer or something, I think
this is obvious to all of you,
if you put it in terms of
something you're already
familiar with.
If you use 16 bit quantization
with fixed bit numbers and
then you change it to
24 bit accuracy,
what's going to happen?
Well, everything is going to get
better by a factor of 256,
and since we're talking about
mean square error, it's going
to be four times that.
So that's just saying the same
thing that you know.
For vector quantization, uniform
quantization again
approaches optimal for
a memoryless source.
If you have a source with
memory, vector quantization
gains a great deal for you.
But if you don't have any
memory, vector quantization
doesn't gain much at all.
The only thing that vector
quantization gains you is this
thing we call a shaping
gain now.
We talk about that again when
we start talking about
modulation.
If you change from a square set
of points to a hexagonal
set of points and you keep the
areas the same, the mean
square error goes down
by a smidgen --
something like 1.04
or something.
It's not a big deal but there's
some gain, so the gain
is not impressive.
The big gains come when you look
at the memory and when
you take that into account.
So now we want to get on to the
last part of our trilogy
when we're talking about
source coding.
Remember, when we were talking
about source coding, we broke
it up into three pieces.
The first piece we called it
sampling, which took a wave
form, turned it into a
sequence of numbers.
That's what happens here.
We then quantize the sequence of
numbers, either one number
at a time or with a vector
quantizer n numbers at a time.
We just finished talking
about that.
The first five lectures in the
course were all talking about
discrete encoding, and whenever
you're going from
wave forms to bits, you gotta go
through all three of these.
Now, sampling is only one way
to go from wave form to
sequence, and filtering is
only one way to get back.
We're going to talk
about sampling.
We're probably going to teach
you more about sampling than
you ever wanted to know.
But it turns out that
it's worth knowing.
After you understand it
you never forget it.
There's a lot of stuff to go
through to start with, but
finally, I hope, it
all makes sense.
But anyway, the thing we're
going to be talking about
today is really the question
of how do you go from wave
forms to sequences,
it's that simple.
How do you in general
take wave forms,
turn them into sequences?
How do you go back from
sequences to wave forms?
We're going to spend quite
a bit of time on this.
We're going to spend three
lectures talking about it, and
probably with today thrown in
it'll be closer to three and a
half lectures.
It's not only because we want to
talk about the problem with
source coding, because as soon
as we start talking about
channels, we're going to have
the same truck problem looked
at in the opposite direction.
We're going to start out
with binary data.
We're then going to go through
a modulator, we're going to
find symbols.
From the symbols, from the
numerical symbols, we're
talking about a sequence of
things and we have to go from
the sequence to wave forms.
So, both of those problems
are really the same.
We're talking about it first in
terms of source coding, but
whatever we learn about wave
forms to sequences will be
general and will be
usable for both.
So I want to review why it is
that we want to spend so much
time on this analog source
to bit stream problem.
I just told you one of the
reasons which is not here,
which is that it's a good way
to get into the question of
what do we do with channels.
But the other reasons, and we've
talked about them all,
and they're all important and
you ought to remember them,
because often we get so used to
doing things in a certain
way that we don't know why
we're doing them and then
somebody suggests something else
and we say oh, that's a
terrible idea because we've
always done it this way.
One of the reasons why we want
to go to bits is that a
standard binary interface
separates the problem of
source and channel coding.
This was, in a sense, one of
Shannon's great discoveries,
and he also showed that
you could do it
without really any loss.
Another reason is you want
to multiplex data
on high speed channels.
This is perfectly
familiar to you.
I think to everyone today we
think of sending data over the
web and we're all used to using
the web all together.
I send my stuff, you send your
stuff, I get my stuff off, you
get your stuff off, and this
stuff was all going over
common channels.
It's going over optical fibers
into MIT, and then it splits
up at MIT and goes into many
places and then it goes many
places again.
But this idea of multiplexing
data is perfectly
straightforward.
If we didn't do any of this, if
all of my stuff was really
wave forms and all of your stuff
was images and if all of
somebody else's stuff was data
and every piece of the
internet had to worry about all
those different things,
when you start worrying about
all those different things you
create an awful lot of
other things also.
We just wouldn't have
any internet today.
So this multiplexing
is a big deal, too.
You can clean up digital data
at each link in a network.
In other words, if I'm sending
analog data from here to San
Francisco and I'm sending it
over multiple different links,
on every link a little bit of
noise gets added to it.
That noise keeps adding up
because there's no way to
clean it up, because nobody
knows what I sent.
If I'm sending digital data, at
the receiver on each link,
nobody knows what I sent, no,
but they know that what I sent
was one out of a finite
collection of things.
There's something called
repeating going on there at
every channel, which takes what
is received as an analog
signal and, in fact, knowing
what the encoding process was,
goes back to cleaning it up
to a digital signal again.
If you believe all of that
and if you think it's
simple, it's not.
We're going to talk
about it later.
At this point, it's only
plausible, and we're going to
justify it as we move on.
We can separate problems of
wave form sampling from
quantization from discrete
source coding.
In other words, we not only
have the layering between
sources and channels, but we
also have this layering for
sources, which goes between
wave form to sequence
separation, then sequence and
quantization into a finite set
of symbols.
Then a finite set of symbols
getting coded.
So, three separate things we've
learned about, we can
separate them all very nicey.
So we said that in this wave
form, the sequence business,
sampling is only
one way to go.
I'm going to show that to you
right away at the beginning by
talking about Fourier series.
How many of you have studied
Fourier series and say
spending more than a couple of
hours of your life thinking
about Fourier series?
OK, good, quite a few
of you, that's nice.
Because we have to assume that
you know a little bit about
this, but probably
not a whole lot.
There's a formula for a Fourier
series, which is
probably not the formula
for a Fourier series
that you're used to.
It says the Fourier series of
a time-limited function
matched the function to a
sequence of coefficients.
Here's the formula.
Here's the function.
You can represent the function
as a sum of coefficients times
these complex exponentials.
You do that over this interval
minus capital T over 2 less
than or equal to t, less than or
equal to capital T over 2.
The complex coefficients satisfy
this equation here.
That's just what you've
seen before.
The way this is different from
what you've probably seen
before is that most people think
that you use Fourier
series for periodic functions.
In other words, if we leave out
this part here, leave out
this, then this quantity here
is a periodic function,
because each of the what have
you are all squiggling around
with a period which is a
sub-multiple of capital T. So
that, in fact, this
is a periodic
function with period t.
If I think of it as a periodic
function I don't have to worry
about this, this still works
for any periodic function.
The problem is this isn't the
way the Fourier series is
usually used.
Occasionally, you want to talk
about periodic functions, but
most often what you want to do
is you want to take a function
which exists only over some
finite interval and you want
some way of mapping that
function into a set of
coefficients.
I take a function only over the
interval minus t over 2 to
capital T over 2, and I can map
that into a sequence of
coefficients, I have, in fact,
done what I said we're
interested in doing right now,
which is turning a wave form
into a sequence.
The only problem with it is
it's a fine duration wave
form, which I'm turning
into a sequence.
Now how do you do
speech coding?
There's an almost universal way
of doing speech coding now
of turning speech, analog wave
forms, into actual data, into
binary data.
The way that it always starts, I
mean everybody has their own
way of doing it, but almost
everyone takes the speech wave
form and segments it into 20
millisecond intervals.
Each 20 millisecond interval
is then encoded into a
sequence of coefficients.
You can think of that as taking
each 20 millisecond
interval, creating a Fourier
series for it, and the Fourier
series coefficients
then represent the
function in that interval.
You go on to the next interval,
you get another
sequence of Fourier coefficients
and so forth.
Now, most of these very
sophisticated voice coders
don't really use the Fourier
series coefficients because
there's a great deal of
structure in voice, and the
Fourier series is designed
to deal with any
old thing at all.
But the Fourier series is a good
first order approximation
to what's going on when you're
dealing with voice coding.
when you're dealing with voice
coding you are certainly
looking at frequencies, you're
looking at formats, which are
ranges of frequencies.
If you want to think about those
problems, you better
start to think in
these ways here.
So anyway, this is not just
mathematics, this is one of
the things that we need to
understand how you do actual
wave forms to sequences.
We're not going to talk too
much about where these
formulas come from too much.
It is interesting that this
also works for complex
functions as well as
real functions.
There's a nice sort of symmetry
there, because the
coefficients are all going to be
complex anyway, because of
these things here which
are complex.
Incidentally, we always use i in
this course for the square
root of minus 1.
Electrical engineers have
traditionally used the letter
j for the square root of minus
1 for the rather poor reason
that they like to refer
to current as i.
In the first two years of an
earlier electrical engineering
education back 50 years or so
ago, you spent so much time
talking about voltages and
currents that using the letter
i for anything other than
current was just an
abomination.
Well, everybody else in the
world uses i for the square
root of minus 1.
So in this course we're going
to do the same thing.
I would urge you to get used
to it because then you can
talk to people other than
electrical engineers, and
you'll probably have to spend
a lot of time in your life
talking to other people.
You shouldn't expect them to get
used to your conventions,
you should try to do a little
to get used to their
conventions.
So there's that peculiarity.
We're also using this complex
notation throughout.
You could do this in terms of
sines and cosines, which is
probably the way you
first learned it.
I'm sure for any of you who
spent more than a very, very
small amount of time dealing
with Fourier series, you did
enough with it to realize that
just computationally going
from sines and cosines to
complex exponentials just
makes life so much easier and
makes your formula so much
shorter that you
want to do it.
So anyway, we want to make this
work for complex signals
as well as anything else.
I do want to verify the formula
for these Fourier
coefficients.
Incidentally, the other thing
that I'll be doing which is a
little bit weird here is that
most people when they talk
about the Fourier integral and
the Fourier series they use
capital letters to talk about
frequencies and they use
little letters to talk
about signals.
For us, we really want to use
capital letters to talk about
random variables, and we do
that pretty consistently.
Believe me, when we start
talking about random
processes, you will get so
confused going back and forth
between sample values and random
of variables, that
having a notation way to keep
them straight will be very
valuable to you.
When you start reading the
literature you get even more
confused because most people in
the literature don't tell
you what it is that they're
talking about and they go back
and forth between sample values
and random variables,
oftentimes using the same symbol
in the same sentence
for two different things.
So I think that's a more
important thing to keep
straight, so we'll always use
tildes to talk about frequency
type things.
You can see that these
coefficients here are, in
fact, frequency-like things
because they're talking about
how much of this wave form
is at a certain discrete
frequency, and we'll come back
to talk about that later.
But anyway, if you want to
verify the formula for this,
what we're going to do is to
start out by looking at --
this is where having smaller
data would be a big help.
u of t is equal to
this sum here.
So I'm going to replace u of t
in this formula by this sum.
I'm going to make the index
m because I already
have a k over here.
When we have a k over here and
you're talking about this, you
don't want to get your
indexes mixed.
So if I'm trying to see what
this looks like, I want to
represent as the integral from
minus t over 2 to plus t over
2 of this representated as a sum
with e to the minus 2 pi i
kt over t taken into
account over here.
So what happens here?
Here we have an integral
of a sum.
Later on we're going to be a
little bit careful about
interchanging integrals and
sums, but for now let's not
worry about that at all.
I suggest to all of you, never
worry about interchanging
integrals and sums until
after you understand
what's going on.
Because if you start asking
about that --
I mean that's a detail.
You look at what's going on in
a major way first, and then
you go back to check that
sort of thing out.
So when we look at this integral
here, when we take
the sum outside, we have the sum
over m of an integral over
one cycle of these quantities
here, of this times e to the 2
pi i times m minus kt over t.
Now, you look at this integral
here of a complex exponential
as it's rotating around.
In the period of time t, this
always rotates around some
integer number of times.
If m is equal to k, it doesn't
rotate at all, it just sticks
where it is, at 1.
If m is unequal to k,
it goes around some
integer number of times.
If I'm thinking of this as being
real and this as being
imaginary, I'm just running
around this circle here.
So what happens when I run
around the circle once?
The integral is zero because
I'm up here as much as I'm
down here, I'm over here as
much as I'm over here.
So this integral is always zero,
which says that all of
these terms except when m
is equal to k disappear.
So that means I wind up with
just this one term u hat of k
times the integral from minus
t over 2 to t over 2dt.
That's another integral I can
evaluate, and it's equal to
capital T times u sub k.
So, u sub k is this quantity
here divided by t, which is
what we said over here.
In fact, that argument,
you can make it
precise and it works.
So what this is saying is that,
in fact, if you look at
these Fourier series formulas,
this thing is pretty simple in
terms of this.
The question which is more
difficult is what functions
can you represent in this way
and what functions can't you
represent in this way.
The easy answer is if you can
think of it you can represent
it in this way.
But if you stop and think about
it for six months, then
that might not be
true anymore.
So if you become very good at
this, you can find examples
where it doesn't work,
and we'll talk about
that as we go on.
Let's define this rectangular
function because we're going
to be using it all the time.
You probably used it when
dealing with the Fourier
integral all the time because
you all know that a
rectangular function is a
Fourier transform of a sync
function where a sync
function is a sine
x over x type function.
If you don't remember
that, fine.
But anyway, this function is 1
in the interval minus 1/2 to
plus 1/2 and it's 0 everywhere
else, which is why it's called
a rectangular function.
It looks like this.
We do it from minus 1/2 to plus
1/2 so it has area 1.
In terms of that, we can express
the formula for a
time-limited function as this
sum here, uk times these
complex exponentials times this
rectangular function.
How many of you can see it ought
to be rectangle of t
over capital T instead of
rectangle of t times t?
Good.
I can't.
I always have to take two
minutes doing that every time
I do it, and if you can
see it in your mind
you're extremely fortunate.
When we work with these things
for a while, you will become
more adept at doing
things like that.
But anyway, this works.
I want to look at
an example now.
And there's several reasons
I want to look at this.
One is to just look at what
a Fourier series does.
Suppose we expand the function,
the rectangular
function of t over 2.
Now the rectangular function of
t over 2 is going to be 1
from minus 1/4 to plus 1/4,
instead of minus 1/2 to plus
1/2, because of the 2 in here.
We want to expand it in a
Fourier series over the
interval minus 1/2
to plus 1/2.
One of the things this is
telling you is that when
you're expanding something in a
Fourier series, you have to
be quite explicit about what
the interval is that you're
expanding it over.
Because I could also find a
Fourier series here using the
interval minus 1/4 to plus 1/4,
which would be a whole
lot easier.
But we're gluttons
for punishment.
So we're expanding in a Fourier
series over the bigger
interval from here to there.
We go through these formulas
calculating u sub k.
We can easily do it for
the first one, which
is just u sub zero.
It's just the average value in
this interval minus 1/2 to
1/2, which is 1/2.
The next term turns out to
be 2 over pi times the
cosine of 2 pi t.
We can evaluate all of them just
going through more and
more junk like that.
But look at what's happened.
We started out with a
rectangular function.
When we evaluate more and more
terms of this Fourier series,
the Fourier series terms
are all very smooth.
So what we're doing is trying
to represent something with
sharp corners by a series
of smooth functions.
Which means if we're going to be
able to represent it, we're
only going to be able to
represent it by adding on more
and more terms, which hopefully
are going to be
coming closer and closer to
approximating this the way it
should be approximated.
Now if you look at these terms
here, these Fourier series,
you will notice that every one
of them, except this original
one which is at 1/2 --
so this is the first term here
in the Fourier series.
The second term is to add
on that cosine term.
The first term is sitting
here at 1/2.
Every other one of them is
zero at minus 1/4 and
zero at plus 1/4.
So when we add up all of those
terms, what we wind up with is
not what we started out with,
but something which is 0 from
minus 1/2 to minus 1/4.
It's 1/2 at the value
minus 1/2.
It's 1 all along here.
It's 1/2 over here,
and 0 down here.
Every time you study Fourier
series you find out about
these bizarre things.
Every time you have a
discontinuity in the function,
the Fourier series comes
out to split the
difference on you.
So you like to define your
functions at discontinuities
as either being here at minus
1/4 or here at minus 1/4.
Then when you come back from the
Fourier series, it forces
you to be there.
Well, what does this say?
It says that u of t, which we
started out defining to have a
certain value at minus 1/4 and
plus 1/4, is equal to its
Fourier series everywhere
except here and here.
I have to ask you to
take that on faith.
But you can see that it's
not equal to it at those
discontinuities.
And it shouldn't be surprising
that it's not equal to its
discontinuities.
I could have defined it as being
zero at minus 1/4 or 1
at minus 1/4, and just that one
point shouldn't change our
integrals too much.
Because of that as engineers,
I mean at some level we have
to say we don't care.
It's only a modeling issue.
Functions don't have
perfectly straight
discontinuities in them.
If they do you don't care how
you define it, it's a
discontinuity.
This Fourier series is sort
of coming back and
slapping us with that.
And it's saying OK, the function
u of t is not the
same as its Fourier series
because the two are different
at these two points.
You say OK, I don't care that
they're not different at those
two points.
They're the same everywhere
else.
A mathematician comes back and
says a function is a function
is a function, and a function
is defined at every value of
t, and if u of t is equal to v
of t, it means that at every
value of t, u of t is
equal to v of t.
And you say ah.
Well, turns out that by studying
Lebesgue theory, all
of those problems
get resolved.
Lebesgue was a very powerful
mathematician.
But you know at some
level deep in his
heart, he was an engineer.
He was trying to get rid of all
this nonsense that people
talked about, and he resolved
this question about how to
talk about these functions
in a nice way.
I mean really, good
engineers are
mathematicians at heart, too.
I mean at some level we
all become the same.
What Lebesgue tried to say is
that two functions are said to
be equivalent in
the L2 sense --
I'll talk about this L2 notation
later -- if their
difference has zero energy.
In other words, Lebesgue said
what's really important is not
what functions are at each
point, but really things about
their energy.
So what you would like to have
is if u of t and v of t, if
the difference between them, you
take the magnitude of that
and you square it, if that
difference is equal to zero,
you have to recognize that
there's no possible way that
you could ever distinguish those
two functions, except
just by fiat, by saying this
is equal to this and
not equal to that.
That's the only way you
could straighten
that out in your minds.
So we say the two functions
are L2 equivalent if their
difference has zero energy.
Well, we have a couple
of problems there.
How do we define that?
At this point, we're sort
of already deep in the
mathematical soup because, in
fact, we're trying to make
these small distinctions and
make them make sense.
We're also going to see, as we
go on to two functions that
have the same Fourier series,
are L2 equivalent, because if
two functions have the same
Fourier series, put one of
them there and one of them
there, and we're going to see
that when we expand it in a
Fourier series they're both
the same, and we're going to see
that, in fact, what that
means is that their energy
difference has to be zero.
Which says that if you don't
talk about functions, but if
you talk about their Fourier
series, all of these
confusions go away about things
having to be equal
point-wise.
So let's go on and try to say
a little more about this.
One of the problems that we come
up with is that not all
time-limited functions, in fact,
have Fourier series,
even in a sense of
L2 equivalents.
You can think of functions which
are so awful that they
don't have a Fourier series,
although it's
hard to find them.
We really want to make
general statements
about classes of functions.
Why do we want to do that?
Well, I can give you
two reasons for it.
The two reasons are both, I
think, both good reasons.
The first reason is that as
we deal particularly with
channels, we have to look at
things both in a time domain
and in a frequency domain.
We look at things in the domain
and the frequency
domain, we have a function in
a time domain, we have a
Fourier transform in the
frequency domain, and it turns
out that nice properties in a
time domain are not always
carried over to the frequency
domain and vice versa.
Give me one example of that.
Suppose you think
of a constant.
The constant function, which
is equal to 1 everywhere on
the real line.
Nice function, right?
It models various things
very well.
It doesn't model physical
reality, really, because I
mean you don't care what this
function was before
the fourth ice age.
You don't care what it is after
we all blow ourselves
up, I hope in not
too many years.
I mean I hope in more than
just a few years.
Therefore, when we model
something as a constant, what
do we mean?
We mean that over the interval
of time that we're interested
in, this function is equal
to a constant.
And it means we don't want to
specify what the time interval
is that we're interested in,
which is a common thing,
because you don't want to set
time limits on something.
Now, you take those functions
which go on and on forever.
Well, the Fourier series, you
don't have any problem with
them because we're going to
truncate the function anyway
before we take a
Fourier series.
But if we look at the Fourier
integral, and we'll see this
as soon as we get into the
Fourier integral, the awful
thing is that what has happened
in the thousand years
before the fourth ice age back,
is just as important in
the Fourier transform as
what happens in the
thousand years right now.
In other words, everything
is important.
Things back in the dim
past clobber you
in a frequency domain.
Things in the distant future
clobber you in
the frequency domain.
Therefore, since we have to
face the fact that we're
dealing with approximations,
since we have to face the fact
that we want to ignore things
-- back there we want to
ignore things there.
When we look at constants in the
frequency domain, we don't
mean that something is constant
over all frequency.
We mean it's constant over the
range of frequencies that
we're interested in and we don't
want to specify what
that range is.
You have the same problems going
from there back to time.
So, as soon as we face the
fact that we're really
interested in approximations,
and the approximations that we
deal with normally in time
are not the same as the
approximations we deal with in
frequency, at that point, we
start to realize that we have
to be able to make general
statements about what
functions do
what kinds of things.
We have to make general
statements about what has a
Fourier transform, what doesn't,
what has a Fourier
series, what doesn't have
a Fourier series.
Now, one of the things we're
aiming at is to define a class
of functions called
L2 functions.
These are basically functions
which have finite energy.
The nice thing about those
functions is that every one of
them has a Fourier transform,
and the Fourier transform is
also an L2 function.
All the other things that you
deal with -- continuity,
things like that -- doesn't
carry over at all.
L2 is the only property that I
know of that really carries
over from time functions
to Fourier transform.
So we really want to be able
to talk about that.
So we want to talk about these
finite energy functions.
We want to be able to talk
about representing finite
energy functions.
I say here, all physical wave
forms have finite energy, but
their models do not
necessarily have finite energy.
In other words, we look at a
constant -- a constant does
not have finite energy.
How about an impulse?
Does an impulse have
finite energy?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: What?
Yes?
How many people think
the answer is yes?
The hands are going
up very slow.
Well, the answer is no.
Let me explain why.
It's something you
should know.
But it's something that you get
blinded by studying too
much signals and systems
before you study any
communication, because you're
talking about all sorts of
transforms, all sorts of things
that you deal with as
functions, which you're dealing
with electronically,
instead of those functions
that you're interested in
transmitting.
If you think of a narrow pulse
of height 1 over epsilon, and
of width epsilon, it
has unit area.
So I make epsilon very,
very small.
This starts to look like
a unit impulse, right?
In fact, you usually define a
unit impulse somehow or other
as thinking of some limiting
process for this kind of
rectangular function.
What's the energy of
that function?
What?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE PHRASE].
PROFESSOR: Energy is 1
over epsilon, yes.
What happens as epsilon
goes to infinity?
Bing.
If you put an impulse into
an electrical circuit
it'll blow it up.
You usually don't care about
that because you don't see
impulses in the physical
world.
You see things which are so
narrow and so tall that in
terms of the filters that you
put them through, which have
smaller bandwidth, those narrow
pulses behave very
nicely, and as you make those
narrow impulses more and more
high and more and more narrow,
they behave the same way after
they go through a filter.
But before that they're ugly and
they have infinite energy.
In fact, you could determine
that from two of the
statements I made earlier, and
I'm sure I can't blame any of
you for not doing that.
I said that all finite energy
functions have Fourier
transforms which are finite
energy, and you all know that
the Fourier transform of a unit
impulse is a constant,
and the Fourier transform of a
constant is a unit impulse.
Therefore, if the constant has
infinite energy, the unit
impulse has to have infinity
energy also.
So anyway, we have all these
functions we like to deal with
all the time which do not
have finite energy.
We don't want to deal with
those in this course, not
because they aren't very useful
in signal processing,
but because they aren't useful
as wave forms which we will
transmit, and they aren't very
useful as source wave forms.
Source wave forms do not
behave that way.
Source wave forms that we want
to encode all have finite
energy, and we'll see
why as we go on.
So now I want to try to tell
you what the big theorem is
about Fourier series.
I will do this in terms of a
bunch of things that you don't
understand yet.
The theorem says we're looking
at a function u of t, which is
time-limited --
nothing strange there, that's
what we've been looking at all
along so far.
It's a function that goes from
minus t over 2 to t over 2,
and we'll let it go into the
complex numbers because we
said it's just as easy
to deal with complex
functions as real functions.
We're going to assume that
it has finite energy.
Then it says for each index k,
the Lebesgue integral, u sub k
equals this.
In other words, this is the
formula for finding the
Fourier series coefficient.
What we're saying here is we
have to redefine that to be a
Lebesgue integrall instead
of a Reimann integral.
But anyway, when you define it
that way it always exists and
it is always finite,
necessarily.
It can't be infinite,
it can't not exist.
It just is there.
The other thing is -- now this
formula is harder to swallow
as a whole.
Let's try to look at it.
What's inside of here is the
difference between u of t and
a finite approximation to
the Fourier series.
Now if you're taking a Fourier
series, whether you're taking
it on a computer or calculating
it or what you're
doing with it, you're
never going to take
the infinite sum.
You're always going to be
dealing with some finite
approximation.
This says that the different
between u of t and these
finite approximations, if you
take that difference and you
find the energy in that
difference, says the energy in
that difference gets small.
In other words, it says that
as you take more and more
terms in your Fourier series,
you get a function which comes
closer and closer to u of t in
terms of energy difference.
So that's the kind of statement
that we want in this
course, because we're aiming
towards saying that this in
the limit looks like that in
terms of having zero energy
difference between it.
Namely, this is going to allow
this function to converge to
one of these strange functions
that has bizarre values on
discontinuities of u of t,
because that doesn't make any
difference in terms of energy.
It says also the energy
equation is satisfied.
The energy equation --
I didn't say it was the
energy equation --
I hope I said what it was.
Blah blah blah.
I have to write it down.
The energy equation says that
the integral of u of t
magnitude squared dt from minus
t over 2, the t over 2
is equal to the sum over k of u
hat of k magnitude squared.
And there's a 1 over
t in here.
There's either a 1
over t or a t --
I'm pretty sure it's a 1 over t,
but I wouldn't swear to it.
I can't believe I didn't
have that written down.
At any rate it's in the notes.
So you will find it there.
I can't keep these constants
straight.
I think I did it wherever
I stopped -- here.
That's where I did it.
That's the energy equation.
Yeah, I got it right, amazing.
The integral of u of t squared
dt is equal to t times the sum
of all the Fourier
coefficients.
I forgot to say this.
This is something
I wanted to say.
This energy equation is
important because in terms of
source coding, if you take a
function u of t, if you find
this Fourier series, u of
k, that's a sequence of
coefficients.
If we take that sequence of
coefficients and we quantize
them to some other set of
values, v sub k, and then we
recreate the function
corresponding to this set up
Fourier coefficients,
we get sum v of t.
So we start out with u of t, we
go all the way through all
of this chain, going through a
channel and everything else,
come back with some
function v of t.
This applied to u of t minus
v of t says that the energy
difference between u of t, and
our re-created version v of t,
is exactly the same as t times
the sum of the differences
between u sub k and
v sub k squared.
Now, that is the reason why most
people talk about mean
square error most of the time,
because if you can control the
mean square error on your
coefficients, you're also
controlling the mean square
error on the functions.
This formula does not work for
magnitude or cubes or fourth
powers or anything else.
It only works for these
square powers.
That's why everybody uses
mean square error
rather than other things.
It also makes sense for energy,
because we believe in,
in some sense, energy ought
to be important
and energy is important.
So, the final part of the
theorem says that finally, if
you start out with a sequence
of complex numbers and the
sequence of numbers has finite
energy in this sense, then
there's an L2 function,
u of t, which
satisfies all of this stuff.
In other words, you can go
from function to Fourier
series, you can go from Fourier
series to function.
You can go either way.
So long as you have finite
energy this all works.
I want to spend just a couple
of minutes talking about the
difference between Reimann and
Lebesgue integration to show
you that, in fact, it isn't
really any big deal.
When you're talking about
Reimann integration --
I've just showed the integral
for a function
between zero and 1.
How do you conceptually find the
integral of a function --
a Reimann integral, which
is what you're used.
You split up the interval on
the horizontal axis into a
bunch of equal intervals
of size 1 over n each.
So you split it into n
intervals, each one
a size 1 over n.
You approximate the value of the
function in each interval
somehow, as the smallest value,
the largest value, the
mean value, whatever
you want to do.
That doesn't make any difference
because as the
intervals become smaller and
smaller and smaller and you
have a function which is sort of
smooth in some sense, then
this Reimann sum here is going
to get close to this interval.
In other words, the Reimann
sum is going to approach a
limit, and that limit
is defined
as the Reimann integral.
So that's the thing
you're used to.
The Lebesgue integral is
similar, oh and in a sense,
it's no more complicated.
What you do is instead of
quantizing the horizontal axis
into regions of size 1 over
n and letting 1 over n get
small, you quantize the vertical
axis into intervals
of size epsilon and you're
going to let
epsilon get small later.
Then the thing that you do is
you ask how much of the
function is in each of
these intervals here?
So the amount of the function
that lies between 2 epsilon
and 3 epsilon is an interval
t2 minus t1 -- there's that
interval where the function
is in this range.
There's also this interval over
here between t3 and t4.
So you say the measure of the
function in this interval here
is t2 minus t1 plus
t4 minus t3.
You say the measure of the
function in this region here,
vertical region here, is t1,
namely, this, plus 1 minus t4,
namely, this region over here.
So for any function you
can do the same thing.
That's the Lebesgue integral.
Lebesgue integral says you
do this and you let these
epsilons get very small and
you just add them up.
Let me say just -- last slide.
Turns out that whenever the
Reimann integral exists,
namely, that limit exists, the
Lebesgue interval also exists
and has the same value.
All of the familiar rules for
calculating Reimann integrals
also apply for Lebesgue
integrals.
For some very weird functions,
the Lebesgue integral exists,
but the Reimann integral
doesn't exist.
For some extraordinarily weird
functions, there aren't even
any examples in the notes.
I couldn't find an example which
I thought was palatable,
not even the Lebesgue
integral exists.
So the Lebesgue integral is
much more general than the
Reimann integral.
But the nice thing is you can
almost forget about it because
everything you know to do still
works, it's just that
some of the things that didn't
work before now work.
Because those things that didn't
work before now work,
your theorems can be much more
general than they were before.
We'll talk more about
that next time.
This material we're talking
about right now is in the
appendix to the lectures that
just got passed out.